mourners gathered at stan swami's
funeral in the city of mumbai on tuesday
after his death from a heart attack
they held up signs reading stan swami
didn't die
he was killed the catholic priest was
imprisoned in october last year and
denied bail
despite his ailing health due to
advanced parkinson's disease
he was the oldest of a group of 16 human
rights activists accused of instigating
violence during a march by disadvantaged
hindus
in state in 2018.
none of the 16 have so far been charged
or faced
trial so there is no excuse many who
knew stan swami says he didn't commit
any crime stan was actually very
committed especially in the last few
years
to the rights of the under trials and he
was trying to help
people who had been treated in this
manner in jharkhand and it's an irony
that in the end he himself became
another trial
and suffered the same kind of
persecution
swami's imprisonment was condemned by
both the un
and eu's human rights reporters we are
deeply saddened and disturbed by the
death of 84 year old father stan swami
while in mumbai's telugu central jail
his health deteriorated and he
reportedly contracted kovitz 19.
his repeated applications for bail were
rejected
one of india's most senior lawyers says
the government is misusing anti-terror
legislation called the unlawful
activities prevention
act or uapa this uap law
and the case has been used to actually
target
prominent human rights defenders and
activists and to put them away
because they are raising questions
whether and organizing people
and protests etc and this is the way the
state is
responding and the retaliating
released a statement defending the case
it's taking against the activists
and its decision to imprison swami
india's external affairs spokesperson
says the government is following due
process in the case and that authorities
act against violations of law
and not against the legitimate exercise
of rights
but human rights activists say the fact
that only 2.2 percent of
everyone held under the anti-terrorism
legislation
over the past five years has been
convicted means the law
must change elizabeth puranam al jazeera
new delhi